it's almost a self-fulfilling prophecy
there's so much talent being sucked into
this thing these guys are gonna build
things that actually have use cases
actually it's actually gonna make it all
work
um you can't have this much talent spend
all day thinking about this and building
in this and have nothing come from it
[Music]
all right we're live what's going on i'm
self-conscious now because we're blown
up on tick-tock i just look at myself
i'm like i should have shaved and uh now
that i have to see myself and i see
people and also the tick-tock comments
are brutal um they're they're good but
they
you know
they're like just want to argue with
every point that gets made so let's talk
let's talk about now when i see myself
i'm like this is going on tick tock
i better i need to shave for the next
one so basically
10 days ago or 15 days ago something
like that like not long ago we told
everyone that we're gonna do this
contest we're gonna give five thousand
dollars to like three people who
take our clips and turn them into videos
the best people are on tick tock so i
actually posted the tags down there for
you so i must have made a mistake i told
people to say to
to use the hashtag mfmclips but then i
also i must have said clip as well
without the s and so people are using
two hashtag clips and clip mfn clip and
mfn clips and some aren't using both
but
if you use those links i i showed you we
have um in the ballpark of around 15 ish
million impressions from these videos
and it's mostly young folks who created
these tick tock handles from scratch
took our
our content
and
some videos have over a million some of
them have hundreds of thousands of likes
they're great and uh do you read the
comments no what do they say do they
make some of us
any content creator you go through the
cycle of like you get excited and you
read the comment and the early comments
are good and then the more popular you
get the comments start to turn mean
and then you just you everybody reaches
a point where they
oh no then the third phase is you say
you don't read the comments but you
secretly do and then finally you know
whatever these are the seven stages of
grief or something uh social media grief
you finally stop reading the comments
because you're like this is just too
toxic so yeah they they basically just
on us for whatever we say like if
we say
um you put down 20 to buy a house then
all the comments are about ways that you
can oh oh you can also not put down 20
if you do this
it's like all right okay tic.com enter
you got me you are smarter than us you
are gonna constantly find some like edge
case loophole or um you know mistake in
what was said do they make fun of how we
look or talk or anything like they
insult us no they don't really they're
either like uh these guys are annoying
like they'll be like let's say somebody
cuts a clip of
one of us breaking down you know our
monthly expenses or something like that
and then the comment would just but they
don't know like the vibe of the pod they
don't know why someone would just say
that out of the blue right it's not
something people normally talk about
so they're just like why did he feel the
need to tell us how much he's spending
on x or like why is he telling us his
body fat percentage whatever they're
just like there's that kind which is
what a douche nobody asked you know why
are you doing that
then
there's the comments that are like
you know actually
actually it's this other thing and then
there's some comments which are like bro
i don't i don't want that future no
no thanks you know because we'll be like
uh here's how things are changing it'll
be like dude companies just only think
about money and like you know comments
like that so those are the three
flavors of hater we get so far luckily
so far nobody's just on our
like face and body oh that's good that's
a that's a surprise that's a win as far
as i'm concerned yeah i and it's in
general sticks and stones may break my
bones but words about my appearance do
hurt me yeah just like don't make fun of
my teeth or like hair
you can make fun of my brain
they um
this promotion has been a home run like
i i thought it was going to be pretty
good i didn't think it was going to be
this good and so what we'll have to do
is there's like a couple people who i'm
recognizing because i watch them that
are killing it we're gonna have to have
them on the pod and explain how they got
so many views it's pretty amazing right
and let's talk about this for a second
because um i think there's something
interesting to learn here so
you have said many times i've grown a
lot of things i've grown an email
newsletter to multi-millions i've grown
a subscription business to
multi-millions i've
uh you know grown uh whatever
you're like a podcast is the hardest
thing i've ever had to grow and you say
that i think it's just kind of a cool
thing to say in general
i agree with it in the sense of it
there's no like easy growth hacks to
growing a podcast
um
there's no just like button you can push
paid ads don't really work nothing
really works like that
the good news is once somebody actually
subscribed to your podcast they become
like a really loyal fan and they like
feel like they know you so it's got a
lot of value but it's hard to get that
easy growth
this is the first and we've tried a
bunch of we've tried we did nothing
initially then we tried placing it in
our email newsletters we tried uh
bringing on big name guests we tried
um paid ads we tried a whole bunch of
different things none of which really
like kind of felt like it was really
working but the pod kept growing
organically
this is the first thing oh by the way we
also tried making our own clips paying
an agency tens of thousands of dollars a
month to be making really awesome
animated clips of our content and they
were great and they were high quality
clips but it didn't lead to this this
was different this was
hey
anybody open playing field
just go for it and we'll give out prizes
to the people who are actually good at
it merit based right and what they're
good at is they understood tick tock
whereas like we suck at tick-tock we
don't know how to create content there
they pull clip they pull the right clips
because they're actually listeners and
fans of the show so they know which clip
is actually going to be interesting
versus like you know some random
employee at our company being like uh
you know at the 42 minute mark let's use
that one for the clip these guys will
put like 10 that they think are
interesting and put them out there
and um
and they're motivated because they're
like if i do this good i can get a
million views on this and i could go you
know i can get five grand from these
guys like that's a pretty sweet deal for
for doing something you know pretty fun
so this has actually worked yeah it's
pretty wild and
like some there's one guy who basically
took our rob dierdick episode and i
looked at his feed and he i'm not i
don't think i'm exaggerating it's 50
clips in a row
of like he basically just took it and
just divided it up and like three of the
fifties all he did was he just took our
talking out and just fight every time
rob talks he grabs a clip which is smart
yeah and in his whole feed i looked at
his feet it was all that one
episode and like three of them had like
500 000 views yeah so go follow them i
think mfm cuts is one on on tick tock
and twitter there's mfm clips and
there's a bunch of other variations of
that name all right i want to tell you
about something interesting i got a few
interesting things to talk to you about
okay um
so let me tell you about something that
i was thinking about this weekend
so i've got a buddy uh you kind of know
them and we i'm not gonna name them
but a few years ago he did something he
was accused of doing a crime that was a
horrible crime one of the worst crimes
you could commit
and he was the uh he was an executive at
a company
and it made the news
so six months later after he went to
court and with the trial the government
dropped the case because it was a
horrible misunderstanding he didn't do
what he was accused of doing and they
exonerated him and they go we're sorry
we were wrong we
we called this one wrong and
the first time the story went out it
made all the headlines and if you google
this person's name it came up on top but
what didn't come up on top was like six
months later it said charges dropped
uh the the misunderstanding came about
for this reason
this person lost their job because of
that
and lost obviously a lot of money and i
was i've always thought about this and i
listened to a podcast this weekend and
it was called um the right to be
forgotten and it was by radio lab and so
this is this idea of the right to be
forgotten and it's in europe it's
actually a law um i don't know exactly
what the law says but it says like
if something isn't particularly
newsworthy
but you're writing about it anyway and
it really hurts that person more than
that provides value to the comment or to
the a reader you have to take it down
and there's a couple of newspapers like
the boston globe as well as uh
in this particular podcast they looked
at this uh company uh this newspaper in
cleveland ohio and there are stories of
like a cop emailing them and he's like
look you wrote about this time that i
lied about uh some paperwork i ended up
getting fired i didn't hurt anyone and
now i can't get a job at another as a
police officer anywhere else can i fill
in the gap on the right to be forgotten
for you here yeah so so basically it's a
law that says search engines should have
to remove links about your past if under
certain circumstances and it came about
because there was a woman an actress
who was in a movie and then he got
dubbed
um so there was that the film was called
the innocence of muslims and then her
her original line um
uh her original line got dubbed over and
then they made it made it so that it
looked like she was saying is your is
your muhammad a child molester right so
that was the clip
and she starts getting death threats and
like people go crazy about this and
she's like what is this like why
like
okay this thing got dubbed now this clip
got on to into the search engine
and it comes up if you search my name or
certain things
and um it's causing you know like harm
to me in my personal life and so she
sued google in 2014 and ultimately they
they upheld it which was um
you know uh
like she would like to have it have the
film forgotten and from youtube
unfortunately the right to be forgotten
which is recognized in the eu is not
recognized in the u.s and so it's a the
eu does respect this as they're tighter
on privacy with gdpr and things like
that and the us does not
so yeah and so in the us we don't have
that but it's kind of interesting
because i personally have seen this hurt
people but you think like right now like
let's say that you're at a bar and
you're drunk and you call someone like a
really bad word and it's on uh
reddit and they find your name you're
screwed like to the point of like
your life is gonna be hurt meaningfully
for like the next decade and like you
should suffer some consequences for
someone's calling something something
rude but not like
that serious you know and so i've been
thinking a lot about this business about
this reputation management business have
you ever researched it
yeah my former co-founder used to work
there so he used to tell me stories all
the time great i want to hear all about
it and i know a little bit about this
because listen to this so one of the
companies is called reputation.com so
there's this porn star named sasha gray
so do me a favor type in sasha gray on
your google and click images
sasha gray
doesn't she's not an actress anymore not
a porn actress anymore but she was like
a very prolific porn actress when you
clicked images what do you see here we
go i'm here okay so i see a bunch of
head shots of her i see no real porn
well i guess i guess some scandalous
stuff but mostly porn
yeah mostly just pictures of her
fully clothed or like in a bikini so one
time at the hustle right when we first
launched i helped write this article
about sasha gray and she hired this firm
called reputation.com
and she basically wanted to retire from
pornography and become like an actor and
whatever else something different
uh and she hired reputation.com to hide
or like basically blog a bunch and write
a bunch in order to get the porn images
to go down and i remember when we wrote
this article reputation.com did
something kind of funny and if i would
go on my google analytics at night i
would look at real time and there would
be thousands of people reading this
article and i saw that they searched
sasha gray and so reputation.com
manipulated it so the article that we
wrote about reputation.com and sasha
gray came up number one if you googled
sasha gray and at night when people were
gonna look at porn they googled sasha
gray and they landed on our article it
was pretty wild i would see it at night
every week or every night it would go up
and so i got crazy fascinated about
reputation.com and so for this segment i
wanted to talk about
reputation.com i think there's yext and
their sprinkler and these are businesses
that do like four or five hundred
million dollars a year and all they do
is reputation management what do you
know about reputation.com
so he used to tell me stories like you
know
i asked him i was like oh what'd you do
you know before this what was your job
before that
and eventually he said reputation common
i got fascinated like you i was like
what is that so he told me he's like you
know here's a scenario you're uh a
senator and your son who has the same
you know john chambers junior sorry
sorry danny john chambers out there it's
a hypothetical so your son who has the
same name as you basically gets a dui or
gets arrested for battery or something
like that so now anytime somebody
searches john chambers
this mug shot's going to come up or this
bad news story's going to come up and
they basically they go to reputation.com
and they say i would like this to
disappear off the front page of uh i
would like this to disappear a
repetition.com says i can't make it
disappear the internet sort of is
uncontrollable but
i can get you off the front page of
google and they're like that would be
amazing and they say for the low low
price of 120 thousand dollars 75 000
whatever it's expensive expensive
significant because they know people are
by the time you're at reputation.com
you're bent over the barrel you they can
charge pretty much whatever they can get
away with so like you know a nascar
driver a politician whoever people of
interest people who wanted their their
names or their kids names to get out of
the bad news and so they had
a team of engineers that were just it's
a constant cat and mouse game to figure
out how to beat google so like
my co-founder told me he's like one of
the big the biggest days at the company
was when we figured out you know google
has to auto complete right so you go
yeah you type sampar it's going to be
sampar the hustle sampar net worth
sampar wife sampar is gay it'll be like
all these likes the same 10
queries for everybody right and what he
figured out was that when you type you
know sampar
if it used to say felony like f would
now say friend instead of felony like it
would they would figure out how to even
finish the autocomplete because
even when they were good at getting you
off the front page by blogging by
promoting other articles whatever
getting them higher ranked
if the autocomplete was still always
suggesting felony then people would
click it and they would search for
felony it would be reinforcing then
google would search for it more so they
needed to clear that so there was just
constant cat and mouse game to
understand how is google doing how's
google deciding what goes where
and then how do we
content farm or manipulate this in some
way that will change what the first page
results are cause 98 of people don't go
past the first page or something like
that
yeah and so it's amazing to hear about
that and then there's a company called
yext
y-e-x-t they're publicly traded and they
do i think that they are just a direct
competitor to reputation.com they're
publicly traded they did 390 million
dollars i think last year in revenue
their market cap is not very good it's
like four or five times revenue um are
you looking at it
i'm i'm on repute i went to reputation.
i just wanted to see the latest like you
wouldn't even know when you go to this
um
what they do because it says this is
their headline
first it looks like a hospital website
like a nice health tech website or
something like that then it says a world
of interactions demands a platform of
action
it's
we're a fixer is what i should say
so but here's the problem by the way
maybe they change what they do i don't
know
i think they still do it i think they
offer like a a smaller package um
uh
like like when we wrote the sasha gray
article that was in 2016 they have like
a 13 000 package
um but the problem is there's there's
kind of two problems with this the first
is that the results aren't guaranteed
like you can't guarantee that it's going
to work which is i guess that's not a
problem but that's just how it works you
know you when someone calls you i get
these calls all the time because i own
domain names and i forgot to hide my
name it's like hey we'll put you on the
first page of google that's a scam you
can't just promise that but the second
thing is that if you're an individual
if you're just someone who like said
some stupid drunken thing to someone one
day and now your name's all over the
place you you it's really really hard to
to like unless you're willing to pay a
hundred thousand dollars which is what a
lot of the stuff costs it's incredibly
challenged to manage your reputation if
you're just like a person and so i was
thinking about like
is there anything interesting in that
space i actually think that there could
be something i like this company called
uh do not pay do you know what do not
pay is yeah i love do not pay that guy
the guy behind it's awesome and it's a
great idea
so do not pay it's started by this guy
and i actually didn't research this so
this is on the top of my head it started
by this guy josh browder i think powder
and he's young like i've when he started
it i think he was like 21. maybe oh 25.
okay well no now i think he's like 25.
when he was started he was even younger
yeah he was obviously and uh he was like
uh like it was like a prodigy type of
thing and originally the business
existed to help you fight parking
tickets automatically but now they have
a bunch of features like it's likely
basically all sticking it to the man so
another feature is like we will um sue
uh
we will sue cold callers on your behalf
or something like that right we'll also
do like um
you know we will unsubscribe you from
stuff that you're not using that you pay
for you know just ways to save ways that
you do not pay which is why it's a great
name and a great idea and i think
there's a world where like a do not you
could use a do not pay service like this
to help manage your reputation online
and this is a need that i think we're
actually going to see more and more and
more of it it's like a very like
exponential thing where it's like more
and more people are going to be written
about and more and more people are going
to need this and i don't know it's just
something i've been thinking about what
do you have any do you have an opinion i
don't know where the new opportunity is
in this one because i think it really
depends on it's kind of like you need
google to exist for reputation.com to
exist and so really it's about thinking
okay there was a version of this on
social networks that people were doing
like um
i remember this one guy came to me and
he was a great entrepreneur he ended up
not doing this idea but like i always
thought it was a great idea others have
done it which is
um when you everybody has social media
where they post stupid stuff uh when
you're younger or when you're just drunk
or whatever and so what they do is they
go to companies and they say hey we ran
a check on all your employees and we
found these red flags and um
you know you should be aware of how
you're
what you know who you're hiring as well
as what they're saying and representing
your company how they represent your
company elsewhere so they end up getting
contracts with companies
to monitor and clean up
uh and they're not like tattletailing
they're sort of like and hey like an
insider helping you out saying hey you
have this employee who's saying this you
may want to take action but the action
might just be to letting the employee
know that we we flagged this as
potentially controversial and maybe they
want to delete it and so it's a
monitoring service for social media
reputations and social media
controversies which i think is shitty
great great idea it just sucks that you
got to do that
well it sucks that the world is the way
it is it sucks well some people think oh
it's good he holds you accountable but
in reality it's just a bunch of like
you know don't don't say what you really
feel is really the result of most of
this because people just get afraid to
say anything because they're worried
about getting cancelled um so you and
your buddy liked working at
reputation.com but they like they were
by the book he was like technically it
was super interesting to figure out how
we do all this stuff
uh you know he's like he always says
this thing at one point we had indexed
every person on the web
and uh
we had like them and their cluster and
their reputation
um and so you know i think it was
technically very interesting but
obviously like sort of soul sucking and
boring as well so he you know bounced
yeah i think i could see that but it is
an interesting problem i've been
thinking about um all right let me tell
you about one more thing
um all right so i was reading the
information uh the information.com and
they had an article about solano so i
told you about this on slack so there's
this solana sorry i don't know anything
about
it really other than don't out yourself
here as a yeah i'm not crypto
nobody
yeah i don't want to act like i'm an
expert here i'm not i just i i i've read
a lot about it though but
news articles so
chris mccann i knew this guy named chris
mccann because he had this thing called
startup digest and that's one of the
reasons why hustlecon became popular is
because i would email chris and i would
say hey can you please put this in the
email and he had this email called
started up digest it started in san
francisco and he would email email each
week different uh events happening in
san francisco different startup events
this is when the startup community was
much smaller and everyone wanted to go
to events and it was just here's a
roundup of cool events happening he
eventually expanded it to different
cities he sold it not for a lot of money
probably a hundred probably six figures
i bet but he kind of worked his way into
benchmark where he like was just an
employee there
and somehow or another invested hundred
and fifty thousand dollars into uh
uh
what's it called is it solano or solano
salon i'm a noob
he invested 250 000 into solana and the
information wrote an article about how
that 250 turned into a billion dollars
is that crazy in probably i think three
three years maybe four years max uh yeah
it's insane i sent you um i sent you
somebody else who also has made multiple
billions of dollars
from their solana investment i said that
uh last week to you but but basically
solana has gone oh like the fun
yeah so solana has gone from let's see
i mean it was like sub a dollar um not
long ago
and now it's two hundred dollars uh per
coin it's basically it's what is solana
solana is a competitor to ethereum if
you know what ethereum is if you don't
know what ethereum is just fast forward
this segment you probably don't care so
um salon is like a competitor to
ethereum and as recently as okay so this
time last year solano was a dollar 54
and
when it launched when it did its ico was
just under a dollar i think it was
and so
um and that was only
that was you know a couple years ago two
years ago or something like that so
basically if you even just take last
year a dollar fifty four you put a
hundred thousand dollars into that and
now you have i think twenty million
dollars something like that um
i'll i'm actually gonna do some public
math here for everybody yeah 20 million
dollars so
um
solana's had this insane run-up and it
sounds like he i think through he's in
this fund called red something red
circle like that a race yeah
race something um
they were like the seat investors in
solana and um
you know that's the right project to be
a seed investor and is a crypto project
that becomes a you know multi-billion
dollar crypto asset and sure enough you
could turning 250k into a billion
dollars that's kind of insane i don't
think it was his personal 200k
necessarily but even if it was the fund
the the article made it sound like it
was but even if it's not that doesn't
change much the insanity yeah it doesn't
change much because he still is gonna
walk away with nine fig over 100 million
some bigger like there but this article
i was reading about it and they're
basically like saying there's like a lot
of
really high profile tech folks at
traditional tech companies giving up
amazing things in order to like flee to
this crypto thing and i'll get and i
want to ask you a question about that
but example like this woman sandy carter
vp of uh amazon's cloud computing she
left uh to join unstoppable domains
brian roberts who was the cfo of lyft he
left to join open c and he said i've
seen enough cycles and paradigm shifts
to be cognizant when something this big
is just emerging and that we're only at
the beginning and it's just gonna get
bigger we had david marcus he basically
led uh facebook's cryptocurrency thing
he bounced to start his own thing uh the
uh this one dude left uh google in order
to become coinbase's chief product
officer and when it went public his
stake was worth 600 million dollars and
then of course jack dorsey bounced from
twitter in order to work at square and
it's like definitely involves crypto
just renamed they renamed to block
because they're focusing on blockchain
but um
it's crazy and my question to you is
this
have you ever seen
someone create that much wealth that
fast and do you have any stories of
people who you know or know of that are
doing this and like what their stories
are because this is crazy
well i'll say the first thing is that
you're right that there's basically a
giant black hole that's sucking up all
the talent in the world and it's called
crypto and it's almost a self there's a
lot of people who don't believe that
crypto is a thing or they think it's
massively overhyped and they say
you know give me one example of a real
use case of this thing nobody's actually
using it for payments or web three
there's no real web three products
and it's sort of there there's some
truth to what they're saying i i
wouldn't say that they're completely off
base it's like a valid critique
um i don't think it's true but it's a
valid criticism but the
it's almost a self-fulfilling prophecy
there's so much talent being sucked into
this thing these guys are going to build
things that actually have use cases and
actually it's actually going to make it
all work
um you can't have this much talent spend
all day thinking about this and building
in this and have nothing come from it
that's like the biggest like takeaway
for me of like even if you're the
biggest crypto skeptic there's a
self-fulfilling prophecy here which is
that it sucked up all the dev talent
sucked up all the smartest people suck
it sucked up like 20 billion dollars of
venture capital every year now and uh
all that funding all that talent is
gonna is gonna create things that
actually do work and do hit beyond
what's already there today so
there's that
now to your question have i seen
somebody get rich this quick i want to
have my buddy on i have a friend
uh who used to work work with me and
i caught up with them and his story he
basically went from like uh
average like an average job like you
wouldn't look at this person say oh
that's a star career
and um they're good they were doing well
obviously but they were doing like
normal person well
and they went from normal person well to
making like
to personally making like 15 million
dollars in the last year
just by
they basically quit their job and they
went down a crypto rabbit hole and
started betting on things in d5 and they
started playing with all the d5 projects
investing their money in d5
and they didn't have a huge base of
capital they had you know
call it half a million dollars that they
put in
and to turn a half a million dollars if
you and if you have no path in your
career to being like
uh
you know a deca millionaire right like
if you don't have a path where you're
like yeah i'm gonna have you money
to go from no path no no like reasonable
storyline that makes sense there you
have a job at a company that pays you
good salary and that's that
to that is amazing to me and awesome and
like
you know just like blew my mind more so
than these guys who become
multi-billionaires who were like
prodigies and like invented the protocol
or invested 250k in a random token it's
like this is somebody who just took
their own money out of the stock market
and was like instead of investing in
apple google and facebook i'm going to
investigate crypto and turned a normal
amount a normal like life savings amount
of money into a life-changing amount of
money and i want to have him on to tell
his full story because it actually has
like a bunch of twists and turns um that
are like kind of amazing so i'm going to
ask him if he'll come on and share it
they're willing to
yeah you know them um i don't know if
they're willing to share but if they are
it's gonna make for an amazing episode
uh i'll ask them if you'll do it next
week did they um
did they earn the did they uh sell do
they have usd or like some type of
stable
currency
um no
they're they're still in crypto like 100
or 100 plus percent because they you
know but but is it stable like a big
like a popular thing
uh it's a mix of popular things and like
something they make
yeah everything's liquid if they wanted
to cash out and say i'm done i'm going
to malibu and i'm going to chill i'm
going to pretend that this year never
existed and i basically won a lottery
they could do that because we have a
buddy in our chat group who said he made
all this money in some crazy coin but
he's like i can't sell it so it's like
that's different that's like uh
those are like either illiquid like oh
there's this coin but it's not listed
yet or it's liquid but there's like no
trading volume whatsoever on this coin
and so like yeah if you have 10 million
dollars and you go to even 100 000 it'll
crash the price of the coin that's not
what this is that's that's a different
thing um
that's a what that is is
i i make a million coins i keep 999 000
for myself
and then i sell one of them for a dollar
and oh now the total value of my thing
is a million dollars and it's like no
it's not really you there's such a lit
such a small amount of the supply out
there being sold it's not indicative of
the true price this is what i'm talking
about is not that situation is there any
other person all right so you have a
story of someone who did 500 000 to 15
million
i just told you about this guy who in
like 200 years this person
non-technical
never was a trader or financial person
like they would own like a index fund or
mutual fund before that didn't know how
to spell blockchain um you know like
this person is that's why this blows my
mind it's not just this like i know that
amount is not the craziest amount of
money it's an awesome amount of money
for anybody but
what's crazy is
point a to point b it makes no sense
it's like how could those two points
connect in that amount of time it's
mind-blowing to me so i told you a story
about this dude chris who did 250 000 up
to a billion you just said 500 000 to 15
million do we know anyone else that has
this like crazy crazy journey
uh personally you've talked about this
guy you talked about somebody right that
you're yeah and a friend that that they
they did
one million to a hundred million
yeah so at its peak when bitcoin was uh
sixty thousand so i don't whatever is
that discounted okay i have another one
uh there is a kid who i call him a kid
because he was actually a kid he i built
this a product called blab back in the
days like kind of like clubhouse-y you
could basically go hang out and chat
with people and this kid used to come
home every day from school he used to
get on and chat and he didn't chat in
the other rooms that had 13 year olds he
came to our rooms because he loved
technology startups he wanted to be in
the startup scene
and um
i think he was maybe 13 at the time
okay so fast forward it's been like six
years since then so now he's like let's
say 21 or something like that
it's been it's been a while
and um
he created some but he was he's a
technical guy but he created a protocol
like i was like oh what you been up to
like how is your startup going and he's
like uh
yeah startups okay we haven't been
focusing on it for last few months i was
like i know man it's tough you got just
hang in there buddy you know just pivot
and find something
he's like actually like we ended up
creating this thing anonymously on one
of these random like side chains and it
was like
blah blah some bunch of terms i don't
even understand it's you know it's a
it's a derivatives perpetual contract
for you know adding liquidity to this
blah blah i'm like okay i don't even
understand what you're saying
uh and he's like yeah the market cap of
it like you know basically like the
market cap of it is like 900 million
right now
and you know i think he cashed out 10
million dollars in this he's like he's
like dude it's been insane the market
cap went up like crazy now it's at 200
million
and he's like i was able to like take
out like a life-changing amount of money
he i took out 10 million he was he was
like he was asking me because he goes
i heard you guys talking about charities
and charity water you told the charity
water stores really moved like i've set
aside seven figures to donate
you're like what i was like you've set
aside seven figures like like are you
seven years old how did this happen
where what if what has happened to this
amount of time like i used to talk to
you when you would come home from eighth
grade and get online like you're
donating millions of dollars to charity
now like what is again a a and b it
broke my brain and i don't mean this as
an insult to them like if they're if
they were only 15 then so they're still
only like 19.
yeah i think they're 20 now 21 something
like that it's been like seven years
since we've made that thing so um you
know it's not it's not mind-blowing to
me that this person is successful in
both cases i
i really like this person that's why i
used to hang out with them that's why i
i used to work with one of them i think
they're really smart and we're going to
be normal person successful
it's like when you know oh i went like
my sister went to high school with this
girl lily galici who's like this super
famous instagram star now and she's like
has her own tv show on bravo
and it's like wait that's the lily girl
who used to come to our house after
school like she was just like a normal
girl like wait that's her like that
doesn't even look like her anymore like
yeah she's had some work done right it's
like just mind-blowing to know a normal
person who's like yeah that's a cool
normal
they'll do well in life to be like no
actually they're like
one of those crazy outlier stories and
in a way that you wouldn't have
otherwise predicted you know it didn't
make any sense like
you know it's not it's not that that was
their skill set and they tried try tried
that thing for 10 years and finally hit
it's like just i don't know where they
just did this thing and it hit and
crypto is this amazing thing like that
so by the way um i want to say something
when i first talked to my friend i
caught up with my friend i felt insanely
jealous i was like so i was happy for
him and i like him and all that but i
was also like
i was like in my head i was just like
what the have i been doing with my
life
with the the friend that used to work
for you both of them both the same
reaction yeah because it feels weird
because you're like oh wait you kind of
looked up to me
now now i'm like you know way less
successful than you uh so like what just
happened you just like catapulted really
crazy like yeah between the last time we
caught up and now
there is jealousy there it's easy
and i just want to say like you know
an interesting thing to observe is what
is your reaction to hearing stories like
this um there's a part of me that i'm
not proud of which gets jealous of it
but that used to be like
it used to be i would feel that i
wouldn't really acknowledge that that's
what i was feeling and i would kind of
find reasons why it was like ah that's
just luck or
um like you know well they probably are
taking a bunch of risk and they might
lose it all and i'm kind of secretly
rooting for it to not not all work out
just so perfectly as it has
that's gone but i still got a little bit
of that like jealousy pain left and i'd
say the interesting thing is
my coach said this to me he goes
uh you know you'll encounter people in
your life where your success just
reminds them of their failure
and they're not focused on your success
they're focused on their fail your
success has reminded them of their
failure or your abundance has reminded
them of their lack
and uh if you notice that in yourself
you want to
be aware of that and change that and if
you find other people and you're like oh
these people are haters like uh you know
just understand what's coming out they
don't actually hate you it's
uh your success has reminded them of
some feeling that they have in
themselves and that's where their
attention is gone and so uh yeah i
wanted to share that because i
definitely felt this like crazy feeling
that i hadn't felt in a long time but
these stories were so mind-blowing that
i could i was like wow
this i don't even know what to say
i feel lucky to
know who i know
which we have the same group basically
that i've like
these stories that sound unbelievably
true
um a big yeah i know that person um
i saw it it was wild so like an example
is
muay's ali is selling native deodorant
for 100 million dollars two years after
starting it i was in he we shared an
office when he was starting it and i saw
him try to learn facebook ads like i saw
the thing come to fruition i saw it
right in front of my eyes every single
day for like six or ten months
um and that was almost half the journey
it's actually pretty amazing you know
and i think about like
this isn't like a one-to-one correlation
because there's other components here
but like i was thinking about this i'm
like jamaica is a very small country
there's not a lot of people there but
they just dominate the 100-meter dash
and
obviously there's some genetic there's a
lot of genetic factors going there but
it can't be significantly different than
america and um and i was thinking like
man one of the reasons being is they
just are just surrounded by like it's
just normal to be great at something and
then and that makes it normal to work
hard and you're like well i should be
running these times in practice and you
don't like freak out you just get it
done because that's what's expected and
i kind of feel that way in terms of
making money because of our friends are
who they are it's like well you just
want to spend something up and if yeah
if you're willing to dedicate three
years like you definitely can add eight
figures of net worth to your like for
sure like it's easy it's not easy but
it's simple and it's kind of cool to
like be around people where you start
seeing like yeah look it's really simple
you just do this this of course you
gotta dedicate
every right you have to dedicate tens of
hours you know 50 60 hours a week for
like many years but yeah it's very
simple straightforward well
the first example you gave with moyes
was starting it literally at the table i
think he sat at the table next to you
right like in the yeah yeah and founders
dojo or whatever those hacker dojo
founder dojo founder's dojo like i think
he was interested at first if i remember
correctly he was like what should i sell
should i do mattresses and he was like
ordering mattresses and like measuring
them and like seeing like oh that's too
much work measures are too big what else
is there by the way the public story is
like my sister was pregnant and she
couldn't find a deodorant that would
have didn't have chemicals which might
harm her baby so i wanted to create that
product it's like dude i know you you
were like all right how do i build i
want to make a business i want to sell
some what do people want oh people
like kleenexes mattresses ah too big to
ship okay yeah scratch that off the list
deodorant small under one pound ships
easily people will use it every month
it's a renewable and there's a niche and
there is a genuine problem for it but
like
i know you dude there's a there's a real
story and then there's the narrative
it's just like
stories not narratives it's not bad he
was just like seeking problems to solve
like boom found it
and i respect that uh i i like that and
that's how i think so you know it's
normal to me the there's something to
when you see it being built day by day
brick by brick
you're like there's a just a respect and
and for me like total joy i never feel
the jealousy in that case like for
example i remember when you started the
hustle i remember when you were doing
just the event and then you were like
i'm gonna do this thing and then i came
to your office with you and john and it
was like like it was like we went into a
room that was like a conference room
that was like the size of a bathroom
and like you had a presentation and like
i listened to it and i was like okay
this is cool but like what about this
this and this some of you guys are like
i don't know we'll figure it out and
then you like you started with these
like long form your original thing was
long-form stories and you like
kind of was working but not really
you're like i'm thinking about switching
to this like newsletter thing just daily
news skim is doing it it's working these
guys are doing it i think we could do it
in our nation i think it'll be even
better
and so seeing that then it's like cool
seven years later sam whatever i don't
know how luck's been seven years was it
seven uh we sold it at about five okay
five years in sam sells the thing and is
successful
nothing but props respect and and joy of
like wow that's so cool i got to sit
there on the journey with you
there's a difference of that watching
somebody build it brick by brick and a
difference of actually this happened in
12 months
um
you didn't get to see the hard work that
was obviously going in and the risks
that were being taken so you all you
hear is like i tried this thing it just
hit 100x 200x like what uh you know it's
it feels more like a lottery and it
feels less like the hard work thing and
i think that happens a lot in crypto
there's a little difference there
the second part is
i remember when uh i moved so i moved
from australia to silicon valley
without having a game plan i think you
were kind of the same way didn't you
just like come to silicon valley like
showed up just showed up
i did the same thing i was sitting in
australia i went i remember specifically
i went to a meet-up and they asked me to
speak about the about lean startups
about startups and i went and i spoke
and everybody at the end was like yay
you know great talk people afterwards
were like wow that was really great talk
and in my head my buddy was like what's
wrong because he could see i was just
like kind of upset he's like what's
wrong he didn't like it and i was like
i was like i don't know anything about
startups and i'm like the thought leader
here this is like i'm doing something
wrong like this is like i feel like not
imposter syndrome i feel like idiot
syndrome it's a blind leading to blind
it's like these guys know zero about
startups i know point one about startups
but if i'm the smart guy here then that
where are the actual smart guys they're
not here and i asked i was like yo what
are the success stories in brisbane
about like startups you guys are not
yeah these guys did great oh where are
they they don't come to these events no
they moved to san francisco these guys
moved these guys moved and i was like oh
all the smart people move okay maybe i
should move so i changed my phone number
first just to mentally be like all right
i have a silicon valley area code i
don't know why for me that was just like
i think i could just do it like over
like i did it in one night before i
could move it was like faster than
moving was just to change my phone
numbers make a statement
and then i remember being like all right
i'm gonna move there i'll figure it out
and i quit my job
you know on the spot and i was like i'm
just gonna move there i play poker for
three months to hold myself over while i
applied for a job
literally one job and uh they didn't
hire me they were like kept stringing me
along and i was like i'm up this
was the one i ended up working at monkey
inferno there was like a slow process
two-month process so finally i was just
like all right i'm just gonna move
there and if this doesn't work i think
i'll get this job but if it doesn't work
i'll get some i'll do something else
what was the title
which is product manager uh like i was
it was first pm there so i
i finally came and when i came they were
like all right why'd you move like why'd
you why'd you come here and i was like
well
uh you know i wanted to see what's in
the water here right like if this is
where all the smart people are that's
where the startups are like what do you
guys know that i don't i don't know and
i was thinking it's about tactics
it's about operations maybe people are
just like literally this is the cream of
the crop these are just the smartest
people and there's certainly some of
that but i'll tell you what to me was
the actual
this was the actual difference the thing
that made coming to silicon valley work
i went to this coffee shop you remember
the creamery or there's like a it's like
this like yeah that's where everyone
would be an ice cream whatever it was in
south park second in brandon i think
yeah exactly so this place called the
creamery it's kind of famous for where
people take meetings and i went there
and i just sat there for like half a day
i was just eating i didn't i didn't have
anywhere to go i didn't have an office i
didn't have an apartment so i was like
well i'll sit here and then i'll go
search for apartments later
and i remember just seeing table after
table next to me somebody would come in
and they'd be like just pitching their
idea to either an investor or a buddy
like trying to make a co trying to like
a co-founder or two friends catching up
or an investment pitch and it was always
like these like hair brained ideas it's
like oh you know linkedin but for you
know cat doctors or whatever this is
these stupid ideas and i remember just
sitting there thinking oh that's a
stupid idea that's a stupid idea
and then i was sort of realizing like oh
that's actually kind of cool like the
normal conversation here the coffee shop
conversation here
is i get to i got this idea i'm going to
change the world
i got this idea it's going to be huge i
was like everybody kind of has bought
into this and like if you go to
hollywood that's what happens like the
waiters and waitresses i'm going to be a
star
and new york is a different thing and
it's it's silicon valley it's basically
i get those i got this idea it's going
to be big and that's normal whereas
before everywhere i lived if you were
the guy who's got an idea and you're
going to quit your job to go do it
you're crazy
you're the crazy guy here you're the
normal guy here if in silicon valley if
you're like i work at jp morgan you
basically have to like bow your head in
shame uh you have to like come up with
some excuse it's like you know because
my wife is pregnant with twins and i've
really got to pay the mortgage but as
soon as that's over you know like i'm
back in the game i'm going to go back
into the startup game like if you're a
con if you work for mckenzie anywhere
else that's great if you work for you
know mckenzie or deloitte in san
francisco you're like the low class
person you're not the high class person
because the high class person is
the founder with the idea or the angel
investor who's betting on ideas so the
just that culture where that's normal
and possible to just constantly quit
your job have an idea throw everything
into it maybe get rich um that's what
makes silicon valley so awesome or at
least that's what it did and what you're
talking about where like if your friends
group has these types of success stories
and is doing this type of
your brain will just automatically
change into thinking that's possible
that's normal that's super doable for me
too and that you can't underestimate
that i think for some people that's what
this show is it's like if you hear us
three times a week
at least that's like part of your friend
group that
talks that way thinks that way and will
make it feel normal to have ideas to bet
on ideas to make a bunch of money to
make huge investments whereas in your
your geography may not be people around
you and your neighbors and stuff like
that may not think that way
yeah it and it basically changed my
perspective from
um like this only happens to other
people to
obviously this is
obviously i'm going to matter of time
yeah i'm going to achieve the desired
outcome it's just um a like for on which
swing am i going to get my hit and b
uh which thing do i want to dedicate
five or ten years on
right because if you like work eight
years on something and you're around the
right people and you've been like going
like i felt like living there i was like
i was in school so it's like well i'm in
school i know like i know it when i see
it and i can just keep working on
something and then i'll see right away
that it's working and then i just spend
time on it and just give it time and it
works it will always work that's kind of
like the attitude
there's um
uh i i think i've told the story have i
told like why i did the e-commerce thing
and why i think it worked
no so
i was sitting with our mutual friend
i think i could say his name maybe we'll
bleed this out later but uh i was
sitting with him and his backyard he had
this you know he has that awesome and
when he lived in california this awesome
backyard with a basketball court and
like a putting green and pool and
chickens stuff like that and we were
just chilling for the day and his dogs
are running around
and uh we were talking and while we were
talking
the shopify cha-ching kept going off on
his phone and he would have that thing
all the time i used to yell at him i go
turn that off too yeah so it was
like
and then like two minutes later
and then i was like i was like what is
that he's like oh my bad i might like
i'm sorry i totally spaced i didn't even
realize i didn't like i'm so
like i'm so numb like i didn't even
realize that was happening like that's
obnoxious my bad i go no no leave that
on what is that he goes that's the
shopify like every time we get a sale it
does that
i said i leave that on because you share
i was like yeah leave it on so it went
on the whole time it goes off the whole
time by the end of the i we were talking
about some other completely we're
talking about dogs and family and kids
and like whatever by the end of the hour
i was like all right man i gotta you
know whatever i gotta go um but i'm
definitely starting at a shopify thing i
want my phone to do that and he's like
he's like he's like yeah you totally
should i was like
just literally that experience if i did
not have that and the jealousy worked to
my favor right the jealousy was a signal
of
if i want that more than what i have
maybe i need to make a change right
because i was like i'm gonna go back to
the office where i earn a fixed
salary it's a great i was making great
money but like it is capped i will make
the same amount whether i do a good job
or a bad job whereas for him it was like
he got to chill it was making money
passively and um and if he did a better
job he was gonna make more money so that
was the first thing
it made me maybe decide i'm gonna do
this and then i started like moyes i was
like what can i sell what can i sell all
right what can i sell okay what were the
other options
of other ideas i had to sell yeah um
i remember going through candles uh
candles are kind of an amazing business
but very competitive candles are
same thing as deodorant you you use them
and they burn out they they literally
melt away and you have to buy them
they're so expensive i just bought a
hundred dollar can't candle yeah they're
they're high aov they're super high
margin so they're not expensive to make
they're just really you could charge a
lot for them you can have a whole bunch
of skus very easily that are all the
same they're all just different scents
um
there are the high end middle and low
end there's candles that are like you
know
oh this smells like your hometown of
missouri there's like a bunch of
gimmicks you can do this whatever so
candles was definitely one that was on
my mind i told you about the crystal
story i was basically like
because i asked my buddy so i asked that
friend and i asked others i said how do
you think about this
they gave me some frameworks of how to
think about it right like
look you're gonna the reason this whole
thing works is facebook ads
so that means you're gonna acquire
customers so something like this dollar
amount all right so you need to how much
was that dollar amount so like 20 bucks
at the time it was like 20 25 bucks
something like that but now it'd be
higher now it's higher now it's like 40
45 bucks something like that but it's
like all right
let's just say in a best case scenario
you're gonna break even on the first
purchase so you want a product that's
gonna have 65 to 70 gross margins so
that means the actual let's say i don't
forget public math but like let's just
round numbers here a candle let's say
the cost of goods is five dollars you
want to make sure that you could sell
that thing for thirty dollars or
whatever to have that type of gross
margin
so
uh and then you're going to have you
know let's call it 15 to 20 is your cost
of fulfillment so that's like
packaging it
um you know picking it in your warehouse
and then shipping it to the customer and
customer
and um okay cool so then you take all
that out so basically you end up with a
break even the question is if you can
break even on the first purchase meaning
it costs you 25 let's say in facebook to
get a customer
then you want that to be your net profit
on a single order
uh then you're basically
that's like the that's like a great
position to be in because you're
breaking even on day one and then
everything you purchase
you build up your customer base
by recycling that cash flow on this you
know every month you're not going you're
not going deeper and deeper in debt and
then as you build your customer base
when they come back and repeat purchase
and you want that repeat purchase rate
to be high so like you know one of our
friends has a thing that doesn't have
hyper refrigerate the other one has like
deodorant has amazing repeat purchase
rate so
if they repurchase that means your
lifetime value will be higher for your
customer and all that extra every next
purchase will be much more profitable
all right and this business would be
more valuable and then little things
like hey the way that the shipping works
in the country is like you know things
that are under one pound um they ship at
this low rate once it's over a pound
shipping is like much more expensive
like there's like a normal usps usps
like whatever
priority mail that if it's under a pound
it's like whatever five bucks or four
bucks or whatever so there's like
certain little things that help and so
like if you talk to moyes moyes used to
like change his packaging so that he
would be at .99 pounds right like he was
like i want to be just under one pound
and that was like his his like keith one
of the key things that helped control
cost
so anyways there's a whole bunch of
frameworks so i went through a bunch of
product ideas to figure it out and then
the ones you're gonna like you know the
easiest thing to sell on facebook is
stuff that appeals to like white women
in middle america so like how do you
sell to a 35 to 65 year old woman that
lives in texas and like that's the
that's the persona that's like the most
easy
to
fish for on facebook you can obviously
sell anything to anybody facebook's huge
but like if you can get one for white
women in middle america like your gold
like because that's what the majority of
your customers are
yeah uh ours are a little younger than
that but like uh yeah that's like the
the white ladies why women in middle
america is like a great market and most
of silicon valley makes a mistake they
go for
what is la new york and san francisco
millennials single millennials like me
and that's such a expensive customer
it's an expensive customer there then
their lifestyle changes very quickly and
they don't need your anymore um and
they're competing with uber and lyft and
like the ad spend it's just too
hard
everything is very competitive it's just
like i guess the way to think about is
not necessarily that one is that much
better than the other i wouldn't
actually say that it's just more like
don't narrow your scope to your single
lifestyle as like a 25 year old dude in
san francisco who like orders you know
every meal on postmates it's like you're
not representative of the world
so
you know like
don't limit yourself to just that um
because like you know it might be
truckers in middle america that love you
know that buy xyz or whatever there
might be just like a different market
that that's really lucrative that you're
not really
paying attention to right now so pay
attention to other groups
so anyways the second thing that
happened was i asked them i asked so we
had two buddies that were doing the same
thing two was enough where i was like oh
if he can do it he can do that i could
do it no problem and um
and so i was like i asked him i was like
what are your sales and you know it
shocked me right it's like oh you know
the business we did seven million our
first year 21 million our second year
and 41 million our third year i was like
what the is going on i was like and
they're like oh yeah we didn't raise any
money it's just profitable
you know i just take a dividend out i'm
like what like what are these words
prophet you know like where i come from
silicon valley we don't we don't say
that word that does what's that what's
that p word
like you know the prophet like jesus
like
muhammad
what are you talking about
so
so when i heard that i was like all
right and then that became my normal
like i was like okay i'm gonna do seven
million my first year i'm gonna do 20
million in my second year i'm gonna be
like that became my what i thought was
achievable and normal if i hadn't heard
that from them i would have never scaled
as fast and sure enough we did you know
seven million the first year now in our
second year hopefully we'll get to 20.
like
i hit this exact i hit the exact thing
to the point where i'm like maybe i
should have shot higher maybe maybe just
hearing their number created like an
artificial ceiling but i definitely
created it
are you how many people work there full
time at yours
um
that's a couple right
yeah like four or five
are you happy with e-commerce i've asked
you this uh like every quarter are you
happy and i say the same thing
it's it's a great business in one way
and it's a terrible pain in the ass and
the other way you know like
you know whatever like right now
everything is it's a lot of headwinds
are going against e-commerce so
facebook's getting more expensive
shipping anything around the world is
getting super expensive and slower
um
so those are the two core costs right
getting a customer and then fulfilling
your product all the material you're
doing physical products and guess what
with inflation everything gets more
expensive
so like
there's a lot of headwinds against
e-commerce right now
um and it's very competitive so you know
there's a bunch of reasons why it's bad
then again it's working and like you
know i'm happy with our business so you
know it's good but would i recommend it
to the next person not necessarily i
think if if you can do software do
software
if you uh if you don't really want to
like
do real work uh don't do don't do
ecommerce because ecommerce has real
work like we have a house you know it's
annoying
let me tell you something really quick
before we are prep i just invested in i
don't ever do d2c companies like these
consumer shipping companies but this guy
listening to our podcast i bet you he
reached out to you too it's called the
good crisp company yeah
so he sent me
like i guess on the podcast i mentioned
that i love snacks or something i don't
know well we know we were talking about
better for you snacks right so so junk
food that's like keto keto cookies
whatever so he's got pringles
that are like better for you than
pringles but they taste like they send
them to you yeah they're awesome i ate
this entire box of like and it was like
a lot of chips like it was it was kind
of messed up it's a can of pringles yeah
and i was like dude this is awesome the
valuation was like two times sales i
ended up investing in it i really wanted
to invest i'm just too i told the guy i
was like you have to amaze you have a
great business
i would totally invest in this i'm just
completely obsessed with crypto and like
every dollar every extra dollar that i
could put into something speculative i
just want to put into crypto i don't
want to put into anything else what's
your crypto stuff that you're that
you're doing now then
dude i bought luna luna's just been like
on fire i don't know if you follow luna
how much should it go up by
well depends which time verizon but mine
is basically i don't know up 40 in like
two months or something
right it's like amazing but uh and and i
think it has like a long way to go still
not again not financial advice i'm just
like gambling so you're here imagine me
saying here's what number i'm betting on
in roulette just take it as that don't
take it as like you know my word
but um
i think there's a lot of interesting
things about it i heard i had heard
about it from a few interesting people
and then i was like all right
um
what is this thing actually and
i can explain it if you want but
basically i i'll refrain for now that's
the that's the thing i've been
interested in good and you didn't do
good crisp that it was a cool company
man
the problem with all ecommerce so our
mutual friend has this great phrase
which is e-commerce businesses are great
to own horrible to invest in
um now i wouldn't say not horrible but
it's like it's great for the owner of
the business it's not great for the
investors and that's only because
the upside is somewhat limited so even
native which sold for 100 million
dollars it's like
these almost never go for multiple
billions but they're often valued at the
same valuations as like a software
company which can become a multi-billion
dollar company and so like you know you
invested i think uh you know i don't
know about that one but i was looking at
other another good deal that was in
e-commerce that i liked it's like oh we
have you know we're doing 10 or 20
million dollars in revenue
you know 20 percent of that is is
profits or ebitda um you know we're
valued at 50 billion or 60 million it's
like it was a good company it was
definitely going to work like the
business was working and was gonna
probably keep working
and um you know the reality is that that
it's unlikely that that will ever even
sell for 600 million let alone six
billion right so it's like you get these
like 2x 3x 4x of revenue like
sales um or sorry evaluation sales
and that's just not super compelling
when you have better options like if you
can invest in software do it you know
and in a couple weeks we're gonna have
this guy on i lined it up aj patel from
high key cookie and zesty paws
that guy's amazing he's one of the most
impressive people i've ever read about
um and he was an owner of one of those
businesses and by the way i should say
two other things
there's all there's obviously exceptions
to every rule so you know i'm like there
are there are definitely some e-commerce
investments that are going to do awesome
uh like native did awesome because it
sold for 100 million but it only raised
i think 2 million bucks or something
like that a million dollars so you know
he was super capital efficient whereas
most of these are not they burn a
ton of money on marketing and inventory
uh second thing the only other bad thing
about ecommerce is like even when i say
oh we did seven million ten million
whatever this year that doesn't mean hey
that's revenue not profits and b
almost and whatever you do have for
profits gets reinvested back into the
business because you're buying inventory
for the next four months so if you're
buying ads for the next month and like
so you're always cash poor until you
finally turn the corner and there is a
corner that you turn when you're a good
business but early on you don't have you
turned it
we have not turned that no um because
we're
like we are like oh great we need to buy
double or triple the inventory for the
next season and for the next season and
after that and so you know it's gonna
stressful as yeah like you know but
it's cool it's like it works but it
works if you don't need a bunch of cash
to pull out um and you're okay being
cash poor for a while real estate's like
this often too you could be cash poor in
real estate but be like you know have a
lot of value yeah but it's not gonna go
to zero
yes
real estate is slow way slow but
it's more liquid and um
it's not gonna grow fast but it won't go
away so it's a little different whereas
your thing
can go away in the sense that if the
valuation drops then you know you're
more you know you don't make a profit
it's not that it goes to zero but you're
you're what you owe the bank is the now
the value of the company and so your
equity can go down right like yes but a
a
ecom business can double or triple in a
year real estate likely will never do
that but that econ business let's say
that like something's made illegal or
there's an embargo who knows like
there's a world where it can go out of
business yeah
for sure
um
i have a couple more i don't know if you
want to stay on we could just split
these into you know we talked about just
like releasing these as like segments
instead of all right hour-long episodes
do you have time or no yeah
all right have you seen this thing that
happened uh called sos sos token no what
is it all right i gotta tell you about
this this is genius okay so
there's a there's a there's an app
called openc or a website called openc
you've heard of openc it's basically not
that big
it's ebay for nfts
um so it's a place where you go and buy
buy and sell nfts and openc is
um
it's in crypto but it doesn't do some of
the things that crypto people like so
it's like it's not fully open source uh
you know all the code is not open source
like they like the website the way the
website works i think it's you know
proprietary it's uh
that you can't just fork that code and
just put your name on it the second
thing is that they don't have a token
involved with it um and the third is
that you know they raised a bunch of
money from private from
from traditional venture capitalists and
in the crypto world that's like a
uh you sell out type of yeah um so
andreessen horowitz i think put money in
it's a multi-billion dollar
marketplace and i think it's gonna be
like
it's gonna be huge i think they did like
um
ben you can look this up but they did
like i don't know eight billion dollars
of transaction volume in like one month
this year so it's been it's been growing
like it's like crazy it is
one of the best startups you can invest
in right now would be openc
now what happened so they their cfo they
hire this hotshot cfo cfo goes on some
shows some either podcast or some talk
show and he says you know we're looking
at potentially going public
and he's saying it because that's a good
thing for the company
and immediately the users are like oh
you're using the old route of like
getting liquidity that's going to make
you guys rich but all of us users who
have built this into the most popular
nft marketplace we're going to get
nothing from that like we don't own
stock in your company so you go public
we don't get anything we built this
thing and again that's against the uh
it's against the core the ethos of uh
of your everything yeah ben just found
it 10 billion and 10 billion in trading
volume in august alone so that's insane
same same numbers um
so
uh oh sorry i think it's yeah i don't
know whatever so basically
um so what happened so this group of
people got together i think the guy the
guy who's behind it his handle is like
um
9x9x9x or something like that right so
this guy comes they create something
called the open dao if you go to the
opendao.com and they say they created a
token called sos so openc is the name of
the platform so this is like sos like
save our ship
he creates this token called sos it
creates a hundred trillion tokens and he
gives them out and what they did was
kind of genius so
on like two days ago anybody who was in
crypto twitter anybody who buys nfts
started seeing oh there was an airdrop
which means if i look in my wallet i'm
going to have tokens it's like finding
20 bucks in your wallet
and so they did an airdrop to all the
users of openc
based on how much you use openc so how
did they get that information it's the
block it's on that's the beauty this can
only happen in crypto so because i know
but i would have thought that like i
guess you could just scrape the website
and just get a list of everyone's wallet
no no no it's not not the website all
open c is just like a website that
accesses the ethereum blockchain so all
the transactions happen on the ethereum
blockchain the buying and selling of the
nft the minting of the nfc is on the
blockchain the buying and selling is all
there and the blockchain again is this
open source public public record
basically that you can go access you can
go i can go type in your wallet address
like your public wall address and i can
just go see how much money is in your
account right now if i just go into
ether scan and so now you might have
multiple wallets but like that's one
thing you can do so what they did was
they went they looked at every every
transaction on openc all the wallets and
they said okay
sean's wallet has spent 10 eth
he's done five transactions um so he
should get x percentage of it so they
took of the hundred trillion they said
half of it we're just going to drop to
all the users of openc so i woke up and
i had 58 billion of these tokens are
there at a point oh whatever price my
total was whatever like 300 whatever it
was like 500 because i don't use openc a
ton i didn't do too many transactions
but if you're one of these people who's
like an nft collector or flipper
who um is very active on the platform
who buys and sells you know you know
board apes and things like that
people made like three thousand dollars
five thousand dollars fifteen thousand
dollars so it's like finding five
thousand dollars in your wallet and
you're like what is this ah i got this
for free money and it's money that they
minted and they basically it was almost
like
it's a marketing stunt but it's almost
like a hostile takeover so they
basically went out there what they were
saying was
here's what opencv should have done they
should have given all the users some
tokens proportionate to their usage
basically so based on how much you've
been using the platform you get some of
the openc token and that and then the
openc token will be publicly tradable so
you get to benefit and the core team
will keep some of the openc token like
the company will keep 20 of this that's
how that's like the normal way in crypto
so the genius part of this is that some
third party just did this on their
behalf and it's like and now what and
they so now there's a liquid market of
like hundreds of millions of dollars i
think it was like 300 million dollars
the the group okay so here's how they
did it they said 50 goes to the users
um
10 goes to the stakers and the liquidity
pool uh 30 goes like the stakers in the
liquidity pool and 20 will stay with the
treasury of our of our foundation and we
are going to build an open source
version of openc we're going to build a
competitor to openc
and all you users who are power users of
openc you now have a stake in our new
openc that's to come that's going to do
things the right way but they've got to
build i mean building now they have to
build it's hard so i mean how
many people work there 500 people
no no no dude these things can be built
by like you know
four motivated developers if you needed
to then why the hell does airbnb
5000 people
it'll take a lot to maintain it and do
customer support and all those things
yes though that will take time but just
building the actual product that will
start to get people to shift off of
opencv to do this a team of five to ten
contributors can actually do this if
they're great developers that are
focused now that's
tbd it's like a kickstarter it's like
hey
we give your money in a kickstarter are
they ever gonna build the thing well it
kind of depends are they honest and are
they gonna work hard i don't know we'll
see
but these guys basically they they
essentially raised
it's like they hijacked open c and they
raised their share was 20 trillion out
of the 100 20
they have 130 million dollars now in
their treasury that they can pay their
development team to build the open
source competitor to this who's who's
the guy behind it the people behind it
this uh 9x9x9x and then someone else
who's x dot xyz that's that's his handle
i think that's who's behind it and so
they um
i think it's
look i don't know if this is gonna work
but i think it's something that's only
possible in the crypto world because
again this is one of this is one of the
reasons why people are like um
you know uh decentralization is cool
it's cool because the users can always
pick up their ball and leave they can go
to another court
and so openc does not own their their
wallets it does not own their nfts they
have no lock-in
to keep the users there
except for behaving well and treating
them well and if somebody else says i'm
going to treat you better over here it
is very easy for me to take my wallet
take my nfts and go over here and then
even better that other group can
incentivize me to come over here and try
it out by saying hey here's some free
tokens that we minted out of thin air so
i think this is possible takeaway
it's like a hustle takeover it reminds
me of i had a buddy
who was gonna do this to a company
called ripple have you ever heard of
ripple
yeah but they they're shady right
okay so ripple was this thing kind of
like started pretty early on um
and they had this like you know honestly
not a bad idea they were like look uh
you know the way the international
banking system works today is off this
thing called the swift standard ripple
was like we're gonna be a bank to bank
communication layer that uses blockchain
right so they're like we're going to use
blockchain technology with a real use
case which is banks sending money back
forward to each other so that was their
idea they got a bunch of funding from
founders fund and others and they
released this thing called xrp that's
the name of their token all right so
whatever nobody cares about that how it
works nobody cares but the interesting
part is xrp has like was worth a lot the
founders of ripple became billionaires
overnight before
like that's the thing with crypto you
can get rich before like this open down
has 130 million before they have a
product
in ripple those guys became billionaires
before banks ever used their product
which is like a really up
incentive and which is why
sometimes doesn't actually get
built in crypto because hey i already
got the millions i could just run away i
could just do a half-assed job it
doesn't really matter at this point i
went public on day one
so
ripple um has a market cap right now of
um
is this right 94 billion dollars i think
i'm reading this right 94 billion
something like that no no sorry 44
billion dollars 44 billion dollars right
that's like that's like the market cap
of like you know bank of america or some
like that so
obviously ripple's not actually valued
at that but ripple had believers and
they had early momentum they were very
early in the crypto games they had a lot
of pr and the ceo would go on cnbc and
talk about how this is going to change
the game so
what happened
in the crypto community people were kind
of like poo pooing riptil they're like
this is like centralized they they took
way too much share for themselves they
didn't give enough to users that's why
these guys are billionaires
their product kind of sucks and they're
kind of shady whatever whatever so the
reputation was ripple anybody who was in
the know encrypted crypto pretty much
the general consensus was ripples full
of
and uh so my buddy had this idea he was
like he was like i'm gonna do the first
hostile takeover
of a crypto network i was like what do
you mean he goes look i can see every
single person's wallet who owns ripple
i was like okay that's kind of
interesting here you go i go but you
don't know their name and all that
because i don't need their name i was
like you don't have their email address
because i don't need their email address
i could just put something in their
wallet and they'll wake up and they'll
open their wallet and they'll see that
they have something in it i was like
okay he goes so i'm gonna go out there
i'm gonna say
xrp is stupid for these five reasons
number one the founders took anyway
people anything
you can include a message in the
transaction of giving them the thing in
the memo of the of the thing but like
the way you do it is you first drop the
token you tell people hey if you held
ripple you got this token today and then
you write your manifesto on your twitter
or your website about what this is all
about so you it's kind of like
somebody put a 50 check in your wallet
you're like what's this all about it
says go to this website to explain why
you just got this 50 so that's how this
that's how this marketing mechanism
works
so he was like i'm going to put some
money in there i'm going to put my
currency in all the ripple holders
wallet and then i'm going to tell them
ripple is stupid for these five reasons
the founders took too much this other
problem this other prop you know their
the right the token is inflationary blah
blah blah
so i'm gonna change all that we only
take 10
we are not inflationary we do not do
this sketchy blah blah blah my
five-point plan of how to make ripple
better
um and we're we're calling it our own
thing and here's the deal if you own
ripple
if you send your ripple to my wallet
i will send you back five times your
value of this if you're in the first for
the first thousand people that do this
then for the next ten thousand people
that do this you're gonna get four times
your your ripple back and for the next
ten thousand people you're gonna get
three times ripple back so basically
there's this urgency of like
okay if these if this is gonna become
the next ripple if i send my money in
now i'm gonna get five i'm gonna get a
5x multiplier on my money and what he
was going to do was just he goes when
you send it to this wallet we're going
to just dump it we're just going to sell
it and we're going to put so much cell
pressure we're going to crash the price
of ripple so if you do it
do they do this or someone finish the
story so here he goes if you do this
early you're gonna get five times your
amount
and you're not gonna sit there holding
the bag while we dump this thing it's
like a prisoner's dilemma game through
it was so genius he's like
he's like here's the math if you're if
you're holding this thing you have to
assess are other people going to take
them up on this offer if they do then
the ripple i'm holding is going to go
down like crazy
i'm going to go down like 5 to 10x
if i
jump if i jump ship i get a 5x
multiplier on my money and i don't sit
there holding the sinking ship
and the game theory of this i think was
gonna work so he has his plan and he
starts and he starts uh and so he's like
okay well he needs to be credible so he
went to some very very wealthy people
and he got about 50 million dollars
lined up to do this hostile takeover and
he was like he needed it to be like 200
million and so he's like i need to
create this huge war chest so i can tell
people look we have this much money so
you this it's backed by something come
on board and he's like dude he's like
basically i'm going to this investor i'm
saying if you give me 200 million
dollars i'm gonna take down this project
i'm gonna absorb all the value of this
project that's currently worth 40
billion
right so he's like it's a huge return
for those investors and they and they
also don't even believe in ripple so
what was this high stakes james
bond what the problem was one of
the investors that he had went to for
this
leaked the plan to a journalist
this guy uh dan primack or whatever he's
like pretty famous journalist yeah from
axios axios axios writes the story ahead
of time he says hey there's somebody
planning a hostile takeover xrp and
here's how it's gonna work
and
xrp obviously the ripple team obviously
sees this and they're like
okay just in case they so they sold
some amount of their ripple um to create
a like
few hundred million dollar buffer so
that if somebody tried to do this and
tried to tank the price they had enough
liquidity to buy back the buy back the
tokens and keep the price high so it
kind of foiled his plan where they the
only the only way it would have worked
is if he had caught them by surprise
and he could have done it in like a two
day period he could have tanked the
price of ripple and created this
competitor and had all the momentum on
his side but because they had heads up
they could create enough liquidity and
they could be able to like support their
price before somebody could do this to
them but how crazy is that dude this is
like some barbarians at the gate
like this is like 1980s like drexel um
like hostile takeover where they like
were like what's it called the green
mailing have you ever read like these
like 1980s finance i have i have the
book barbarian i haven't read it yet uh
yeah that's basically what they did like
it was like
it was like warfare i was like this is
some george soros you know that
george soros broke the bank of england
yeah i was like
that's actually what he was telling me
he goes this is some george soros
and i was like what do you mean he goes
george soros broke the bank of england
by doing something very similar to this
and as he was explaining i was like
there's no way this works he's like well
you know it's risky but like if it works
who who did it and so he didn't he
didn't end up doing it um but i mean who
who's that it's an artist is it public
uh i don't know if it's public but i'll
tell you
actually it's our friend who remember we
went to dinner after our live show in
miami it's our friendly way yeah okay
okay yeah
um
that's crazy i thought uh if if dan
would have wrote about it he would have
named him yeah i think he didn't know
the name or he i don't think he included
the name of the thing but how
nuts is that that's crazy if you can if
that person could have pulled it off
that's wild
this is barbarians at the gate
hostile takeover stuff yeah i love it um
all right i have a couple more topics if
we want to do them or if we want to go
we can go
all right i got i can do 15 more minutes
all right let's do one more um
okay i got two random ideas for you okay
here's the here's the first idea
all right this idea is my gift to the uh
chief marketing officer of gucci you
know you're welcome courtesy of shop
party okay i see this headline
[Laughter]
all right so i was thinking the other
day i was i was sitting there
and sitting at the at a restaurant
and as i do i'm just watching i'm just
people watching i'm just watching these
crazy creatures called humans what the
what the are they doing and i
saw all these people that had
fancy bags gucci bags louis vuitton bags
it's very different from my world i
don't i don't give a about that but
they obviously do i was watching this
then i came home i'm watching this show
selling sunset funny show on netflix
about real real estate teams dude i
watched it too man
you know i watch all that
yeah so so you know i dabble and uh if
you notice every day they come to work
they're wearing like the craziest like
what nobody wears to work they're
wearing like five thousand dollars
dress with like a five thousand dollar
bag and they put the bag right on the
middle of the desk it's like there's no
laptop there's no computer it's like a
desk with a chair and their purse on top
and then they just close up with each
other right that's where the show is at
this point
so
i was thinking about this like luxury
thing the luxury's just caught my eye i
said what else
what else could you do and and i don't
know how this came to mind but
here's a crazy idea it's really a
marketing stunt it's not a business idea
it's a marketing stunt for gucci so
here's what you're gonna do every year
there are over a million joint
replacements in america
so people getting hip replacements knee
replacements people getting you know
they they fracture their foot they get a
steel rod put in there are over a
million people a year that get this done
i got it done
you got that what'd you get done
i've got screwed i broke my leg i've got
screws and a little i got metal on my
feet now you're not the right person to
ask but is there a version of sam
that might have paid an extra 500 bucks
to have that be a gucci nail the answer
is yeah of course the answer is yeah
the answer is yeah so we're talking
about i thought you were gonna go with
like gucci prosthetic legs yeah but
you're talking about like just brandon
on the internet that's actually a cool
idea inside and you only see it on the
x-ray like
you you have the picture before it goes
into your body right so you get the
instagram porn of okay hey guys i'm
doing well post surgery
here's my picks and as you're swiping
it's an awesome phone it's a
louis v hip that's coming into your body
that's an awesome flashlight
dude you can always see that in
airplanes
they do something so that exactly in
x-ray you'll always see an emblem on the
thing now i don't know how uh doctors
will figure out the science of how this
works without up here pretty
great that's good how good is that dude
that is
that is amazing this is just an extra
little revenue line tons of news because
everyone's going to say this is what's
wrong with the world you're going to
take over and guess what there's going
to be a bunch of people out there who
are going and getting surgeries done
that are going to say yeah okay it's the
average knee replacement
is like 25 30 000 like all lint uh i
think that you know maybe it can be as
low as 12 to 15 000. you tell him in the
actual part itself that goes in i think
is a 5 000 part that the hospital orders
you're telling me i wouldn't get the 7
supreme
you know
the nike logo
come on yeah come on yeah that's just
licensing revenue for them
it's working
it's it's influencer candy dude it
if people get grills if rappers go get
diamond grills if they're if you know
somebody out there like me some some guy
like me out there was like yo
diamond braces what
yeah diamond braces actually it not
even for braces just diamond teeth
diamond teeth worked if diamond teeth
worked the louis v hip could work dude
this is a good idea this is pretty funny
this is brilliant this is actually a
good that one was for you for tic-tac
that's for you tic-tacs out there that
was my tic-tock segment that's actually
this is actually a fun idea
all right
wait who who
did you research this is that even
possible i have no idea if it's possible
i've got like
i don't think you could
i don't think you could see stuff like
that i've got x-rays of my screws and
like you can like look at them but i
don't think i i don't know how that
would work but it might have to be a
striping it might have to be a dots
polka dots it might have to be something
that will show up there might be an
emblem that's just on it a tiny emblem
uh but you know like the red bottom
shoes uh for what's it called you know
like
yeah i don't know
yeah we're nerds but the the
black uh or the red bottom shoes they
rap about them yeah
exactly whatever people will find a way
to see the and you just if that's
the only problem with this idea we got a
good problem to have so um and also by
the way tattoos i think you could also
do this with tattoo parlors i think you
could drop
branded official licensed designs
of tattoos for brands
and be like yeah if you get this one
it's actually that's like actually the
brand
because like you people get tattoos of
brands like yeah like a louis vuitton i
think jake paul has a nike swoosh where
his like sock would be on his on his
calf
that's hilarious actually and i was like
that's funny he got a brand tattooed on
him and i think i was also like yo why
wouldn't brands actually drop tattoo
designs just like they dropped bag and
shoe designs like i feel like that
should happen that's interesting that's
another interesting idea all right two
for two all right i have one more for
you okay this one's less fun but i think
it's still good
do you remember glamour shots
love them
did you your mom have glamour shots do
you know anybody who has no but i didn't
do it but like my sister did it's
hilarious it's like napoleon dynamite
where you go to the mall
and you wear stupid makeup and a bad
haircut and you take these awesome
pictures of course do you know the
business behind glamour shots no
uh okay so is that is that the name of a
brand glamour
uh glamour shots was the name of the
company i think okay so here's the
here's the quick backstory i did like uh
you know two seconds of research on this
so could be wrong
started by a frat party photographer who
was like you know taking pics at frats
and i was like all right what else i got
so initially starts it calls it party
pics
then when they were like kind of looking
at trends they were like oh people are
liking this like high glamour style like
big hair loud loud clothes certain
backdrops and so they were like all
right um
he's like so renames it to glamour shots
and it's physical locations and within
first year it already starts working by
year three seven million in revenue and
copycats popping up everywhere hollywood
headshots freeze frame you name it
there's different portrait shops popping
up at one point it just expands through
the franchising model expands to 380
stores taiwan japan everybody wants a
piece of glamour shots and the trick the
thing that like really made it work was
most great name most professional
photographers you would go well there's
a couple things made to work one was the
style was iconic
the second was so it wasn't just come
i'll take a picture of you was come i'll
make you look like a hollywood star with
the hair the makeup the clothes and it
was only like you know
top half up so you would be wearing your
jeans underneath and then your top would
be like this denim studded jacket or
whatever with the collar pop or whatever
so backdrops with the colors everybody
knows the look fan blowing your hair
that whole thing so that was one one
innovation the other was
instant gratification so you would take
the photo and for most photographers
they're like great i'll
i'll go you know get these exposed then
i'll um i'll uh whatever touch them i'll
pick the best ones i'll get i'll get you
you know some some options in a few few
days few weeks glamour shots they used a
special like kind of camera technique or
whatever so it was actually taking a
video i think and it would grab an image
and you could see it right there on the
screen in real time and you could pick
and be like oh i want that one that
one's so good they got you in the heat
of the moment when you were in peak
state when you were already caught up in
the frenzy and people were dropping
300 400 500
inflation adjusted for on their glamour
shots um
[Music]
average customer spend so it was like
highly lucrative because that's
basically like you know for like a 30
minute shoot you're making you know huge
profits and they had these like six
categories of styles that you got to
pick from the names are hilarious one is
can't wait to be touched
another spontaneous
tailored elegant bold and that's where
these like classic looks come from so
there was some genius behind the person
who really understood what the customer
wants behind it whatever happened to the
company so it gets to 100 million in
sales by 1994.
by 2001 it's now dropped back down to 93
stores now there's like 40 stores left
it's basically withered away and dying
it didn't didn't last didn't keep up
with the times
here's the idea
right rebooting glamour shots and we're
rebooting glamour shots
everything nostalgic from the 90s is
crushing oh you're rebooting spider-man
batman
x-men
you're rebooting home alone home alone's
getting rebooted we're rebooting glamour
shots that's what i'm telling you i'm on
board so there's i'm looking at it now
there's only five so there's only five
of these locations left yeah they're
we're down to the last stones you know
remember the alamo where we're down to
the last stand so the question is how
would you actually rebuild glamour shots
so i wanted to brainstorm with you for
two minutes how would you reboot glamour
shots i got a couple ideas i don't know
if you have one off top your head
otherwise i'll go
you gotta do it in person i think i
think that's
that's part of it
um
do what do you need to do that's
different i mean you just do an ad
campaign with really cool celebrities or
some celebrities and you'd be like
here's what they would have looked like
like you know a modern a modern person
what they would look like with a glamour
shot what would you do so i i'm going to
reboot it i'm not okay so nostalgia is
one cat one one angle you could you
could just say this look would come back
uh but i think that's that's
short-sighted i think what you got to do
is you got to work backwards so my mom
had glamour shots on the wall the end
product was a framed picture on the wall
of her looking like an 80s soap opera
90s soap opera person basically with the
hair blown out and crazy lighting and
crazy dress
well what is the what's the end product
people want today
instagram baby they want epic instagram
content so we've talked about museum of
ice cream we've talked about some of
these i think those are secretly glamour
shots reboots i think you gotta go all
in on the glamour shots reboot so
you're gonna you're gonna make somebody
look amazing
for social media i know how people out
there are throwing up in their mouth
they're like oh this is everything
that's wrong with well guess what people
people care what they look like how they
come across on social media if you if
you hate that fact cool delete instagram
but if you still got instagram you're
still in on this idea okay so how are we
gonna do it
one idea was could you get airbnbs
convert them into like basically like
dope lifestyle looking airbnbs and just
rent them out for shoots
instead of you know renting it out for
seven hundred dollars a night you're
renting it out for a hundred dollars an
hour and you're doing 200 an hour and
you're doing shoots for people
where they get to look like they live in
a dope lifestyle they look like they're
living but that's that's different than
a glamour shot a glamour shot is like
supposed to be funny
it's not supposed to be funny dude that
it looks funny now when we look back
like i look back at your dad with an
afro or whatever like actually you had
an afro in high school so if you look
back at your own high school that's
supposed to be funny at the time i don't
know if you were trying to be funny but
for glamour shots like they are they're
trying to be grammar but that's
different with these instagram things
you're talking about be like lying
you're trying by looking cool yeah so so
that's one one angle to it
i think you're lying you don't live in
that fancy-ass house yeah but you're not
saying i live here you're just posing a
picture like people do this we're gonna
have like a like people rent fancy cars
and they take pictures with it and then
they've returned the question you know
anyone who does that
personally thank god no
have i seen the people who do that on
instagram yes i've seen people do it on
instagram tons of people do that on
instagram it's like uh what you would
need is people write dresses for the day
you know dude you would just need like a
like one airline seat and like what yeah
dude you've seen that right
the half private jet it's like a movie
set it's like where they film pornos
exactly so so there's that i think okay
but that's a little capital intensive to
get airbnb's maybe you do it with a
green screen so i think one one way you
can do this is you could just have
someone come take pictures with a green
screen and you just do it where once
they take the pictures once in one of
your locations with a green screen very
cheap to do
then you cgi them into like a whole
bunch of different looks that becomes
their collection of of like
they could be power suit they could be
it could be boss mode they could be
party mode they could be whatever but
you just have green screen props and
scenarios and you show them exactly how
to pose to look good most people don't
even know how to pose myself included
when you meet somebody who knows how to
pose you're like oh like that's
half of it the other half is like
lighting and props but like and
editing right like but
do you remember when the guy came to
take photos of us at the miami thing he
was like all right stand here
half squint your eye you're like why
yeah i was like i was like
down syndrome what do you mean he's like
no trust me kind of squint your eye he's
like then
you know like protrude your neck forward
i was like no this looks like a turtle
he's like no look watch i got rid of
your double chin you know you look like
sharper and like more powerful okay look
at this angle this this gives you
confidence look from this angle
specifically whereas for me i'm like the
nutcracker if i take a photo
it's like stand straight look straight
hands on my side smile cheese like
that's how i take all my photos right
but there is an art to posing and most
people don't know how to do it so i
think there's a there's a version of
glamour shots that somebody could reboot
that just gives you an end product that
you want for social media i don't know
exactly i would just say i would just
say bring back the classics i think that
you could just you could just do it as
is
what happened to the company so did it
dude you could just do this with like
dating profiles and stuff whatever um
i don't know the company still exists
but i think it's kind of like just gone
down the drain i don't know i i don't
know the ending of that story
i wonder what happened to the founders
does he have like some his name's bob
does he have like some huge
like mansion now in la like that glamour
shot money
one thousand percent he's going to have
a huge mansion advantage
take two seconds to just google that i
bet you
i bet you this guy's got to have a thing
in l.a and if he doesn't we're just
going to edit this part out
uh
i can't see but
is it actually bob ooh he lives in texas
in dripping springs texas which is near
austin and it's where like it's like
where moms who get glamour shots live
it's like the suburbs of texas by the
way that's the glamour shots is still
thriving in texas i think that's the
only place where it's still like a
thriving business i think i read that
dude this guy's awesome
that's all i got those are my topics
this is awesome we got to get bob on
here um all right that's the pod
[Music]
you